Speaker 1: So in the last segment,
we looked at the Trump rally itself.
Twenty twenty two has officially started.
Trump did a rally in Florence, Arizona. It
was riddled with lies. It was riddled with
sort of a fascist, authoritarian delusions,
and it was crazy. And Trump's doing another
rally on January 29th. The thing I want to
get to now is that people were interviewed
at the rally and these are sick, dangerous
people. But what's really interesting is that
some of the crazy people at the Trump rally now
are not even pro-Trump. We've talked about this
split that has happened where you you've always
had the anti-Trump and the pro-Trump
Republicans, but now you also have the
pro-Trump and the formerly pro-Trump Republicans.
And I'm going to play a couple of clips for you,
right side broadcasting, actually doing something
interesting, which is as crazy as they are.
They were interviewing people that are like, too
crazy, even for them, where the interviewer dude
starts to kind of try to get away. Let's go to
this first one. This is a sort of a former Trump
person, and you've got to really go line by line
to understand the insanity. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: A good what's your
name? Where you from? My name
is Kyrie Billingsley a.k.a. Flat Earth boxer.
Speaker 1: OK, so first of all, this guy's a flat
earth or his nickname is based on being a flat
earth. Or so that's number one. Let's continue.
Speaker 3: And it's my it's my persuasion
that it's clearly the apocalypse and that
the vaccine is made of aborted children.
Speaker 1: Now, the vaccine is not made of aborted
children. That's a lie. And in keeping with all of
the different, you know, anti-Covid disinformation
rules on all of our various platforms, I feel
like I don't want to treat you in the audience
like morons because I know, you know, that's
not true, but I have to say the vaccines are
not made from aborted children. That's a lie.
Speaker 3: And a vaccine may regard children being
fast tracked by one man named Donald J. Trump.
Speaker 1: Now, that's interesting, he says,
that the vaccine was fast pract by Donald Trump.
That's not even true. A lot of these anti-vax
people now are mad at Trump because Trump
said the vaccine works to keep you alive,
but they wrongly credit Trump with getting the
vaccine. Seen done faster. That's something Trump
wants you to believe, it's not even actually true
Speaker 3: who the world's kind of ally of the
Jewish world suspecting might be
a very, very good thing for their
Speaker 1: interests. Now there it goes into
anti-Semitic conspiracies. The idea that
the deadly vaccine made from aborted
children is something the Jews want to use
to fill in the blanks. It doesn't really
matter, but anti-Semitism is often lying there
at the surface with a lot of these people.
Speaker 3: But these vaccines may have
aborted children, and as for a
virus that doesn't exist and now
Speaker 1: COVID does exist. The gentleman says
Corbett doesn't exist. COVID does exist. We're
just remaining in compliance here at
Speaker 3: pretending it does. And the
problem with that is that if everyone's being
compelled to edit their genetics with this
Speaker 1: vaccine, now, remember
that the vaccine does not edit
your genetics. That's a lie to children.
Speaker 3: That's a lot like the days of Noah,
and there've been signs in the heavens
pursuant to all these things, and the
vaccines came out exactly one thousand two
hundred sixty days following this sign.
Speaker 1: I have to admit, I don't know the
meaning of one thousand two hundred and sixty days
or the religious part. It's less relevant to me
Speaker 3: came like in Israel. So it's
literally the mark of the Beast, and a
lot of people aren't talking about it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, good. It is true that a lot of
people aren't talking about that because it's not
worth talking about, but OK, so that's bonkers.
Then they go and they interview another guy,
and this guy says that Gavin Newsom
is dead. Apparently, Gavin Newsom,
the Democratic California governor, is
a body double of some kind. And again,
this stuff starts to get too crazy even for the
interviewer, like the interviewer starts backing
away and the interviewer is out of his mind.
Speaker 2: Well, and nurses are calm. OK,
they just took him out here.
Speaker 1: So he says,
this gentleman says Gavin Newsom is a clone.
There's no evidence that Gavin Newsom was cloned
Speaker 4: puppies for a little while. He's
he's real. He's a different level. You're right.
But the real governor Newsom has had his
military tribunals at GITMO, and he's been
executed. OK, well, there you go. Thanks.
Speaker 1: There you go. He says the interviewer.
And then lastly, and you guys tell me whether
this is child abuse. Here is an interview with
a 12 year old at the rally and what's going
on at home that has led to this, you know.
Speaker 4: 12. What is it about being a
Republican that you're that that made you
decide to say, I'm a Republican? Like, What is it?
Speaker 1: I'm an a publican. I'm Anna publican.
Speaker 4: Just my parents really like, talk to
me and and they they didn't really force on me
I could have picked. They wouldn't care, right?
Speaker 1: I somehow think that the mom wearing
the Trump full regalia would care if this kid was
a progressive. Tell me up, you know, convince me
I'm wrong. I think she would care if
Speaker 4: who I picked,
who I wanted my freedom and liberty and
love in the country and the guns he like.
Speaker 1: Yes, 12 year old
likes guns. OK, so he likes
guns and he's a Trumpist. What a beautiful day.
Speaker 4: And your Second Amendment, right? Yes,
that's protected by the Constitution. Yes, right?
You just can't rewrite it when you want to rewrite
it. Like if you don't like guns, you don't get
to say, Well, I'm just going to race the gun part
and right writing my own.
Speaker 1: Now, of course,
there have been no modifications of the Second
Amendment that have been made by Democrats or
whatever he's talking about.
Speaker 4: You don't have that
option yet. All right. The best country
in the world. We live in, the best country
in the world. You got to get mom to your parents
like that. Thank you very much. Twelve years old.
We'll see in six years. I expect you to vote.
Speaker 1: All right. So extremely disturbing
stuff. It's I don't even know that I have more of
a commentary other than to say we have a really
horrifying situation in this country right now.
If you've just been listening today, we'll have
these clips in video form on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.